meanwhile blm riders are celebrating
the attempted murder of two cops
you you may have seen this video this
happened in i think this happened in
l.a while i was while i was away or just
getting back
some thug walks up to two cops sitting
in a car totally unprovoked
and shoots the two cops then blm
activists blocked the hospital
where they were supposed to be treated
they blocked the emergency room
because they wanted the cops to die take
a listen
all right it's hard to hear because you
got to bleep so much of this guy but uh
he says yeah i hope they effing die who
are they
31 year old mother and a 24 year old man
think about this think about what think
about the me too movement we're told
that if a man treats a woman
if a man propositions a woman that
that's evil and awful if a man asks a
woman out on a date in an inappropriate
situation that's evil and awful terrible
but a man can go shoot a 31 year old
mother totally if a man
god forbid beats a woman beats his wife
beats his girlfriends like the worst
thing ever right
but then this man goes up and shoots a
31 year old mother
and prominent left-wing activists a blm
movement right which is
which has tormented our cities for
months now
says oh that's all well and good what
happened to that kind of stuff by the
way what happened to me too with cuties
cuties is sexually exploiting these
young girls all in the name of opposing
sexual exploitation of young girls okay
but they're
sexually exploiting them altering the
metoo movement
what kind of a country celebrates this
stuff
what kind of a country what kind of
country do we want to have
what kind of country do we have i hope
you enjoyed this segment of
the michael knowles show and you should
know on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael noll show youtube channel
because that just makes sense doesn't
it's right there it's right there in the
name
there is a link in the description below
head on over
subscribe to the michael knoll show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]